a salt lake city police officer is
suspended this morning
after ordering a police dog to attack a
black man during a brutal arrest
newly released police body camera video
shows how the encounter
unfolded jeffrey ryan's is
now preparing to file a lawsuit claiming
officers used excessive force
carter evans is following the story we
want to warn you
some of those images will be disturbing
get on the ground and you're going to
get bit that k9 officer made good on the
threat
even though jeffrey ryan appears to
comply with the command
holding up his hands and moving to the
ground
why are you biting me
as soon as i got on the ground i hear
the canine and you just start
tearing up my leg i'm not running or
anything i'm cooperating like why are
you doing this
the officer keeps ordering the dog to
hit or
bite even after ryan's is handcuffed in
on his stomach
ryan says he lost his job and had to
endure multiple surgeries
doctors tell him amputation is still a
possibility
police say they were responding to a
call that ryan's was fighting with his
wife who had a protective order against
him
but ryan says that order was about to be
lifted and he'd been living at home with
his wife for weeks
deputy police chief jeff kendrick
explains why the k-9 was there
domestic violence calls are some of the
most dangerous calls that we respond to
so officers you know use extra
precautions when they respond to
someone's home
on the ground the incident happened in
late april of this year but police
only launched an investigation this
tuesday when the body cam video was
released
the arresting officer was suspended
wednesday and the mayor said use of
canines are also suspended
pending a full investigation
[Applause]
for cbs this morning i'm carter evans